[Music]
are you guys the type of people
to road rage i was good rich
road rage bro well like i'll talk [ __ ]
out of it
i'll be like what the [ __ ] and then i'm
kind of over it are like road rage
people in denial though
danielle what denial they're like i
don't real rage what the [ __ ] at the
[ __ ] up like
road rage people i don't know okay
does this define road rage so if i'm
driving and someone does some [ __ ] i
will cuss but then i'll also
if i'm in the mood which most likely i
am i will be getting like i'll tailgate
a little bit like what the [ __ ]
and then i'll i'll go next to them and
try to like avoid them avoid that car
because they ended up like [ __ ]
swerving into my lane or they did some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] to me
obviously i felt wronged enough to be
upset
to curse and to do this [ __ ] i mean
if you're tailgating that's a bit of a
road trip a little bit of tailgating
you look at them when you pass them by
uh
and then um yeah and so i'll try to
avoid that car so i'm like
moving like swerving or awake not
swerving but changing lanes
away from them yeah is that our roadway
i
[ __ ] yeah that's road rage you get an
emotional response and a
form of anger and whatever you do next
is out of the ordinary
ah then i guess i do your boy got road
rage too
yeah i don't anymore you don't try not
to i'm not stressed out anymore
yeah oh i have been a lot less for sure
in the past it was more
like when you're stressed out it's
easier to get road rage yeah yeah i try
to drive slower now when i try to drive
a little safer
because before i would i would get
pretty upset usually what would happen
is like if somebody
does something very dangerous to me i'll
get really upset but all they have to do
is just be like yo
my bad and then i'll be and usually i'll
be yelling and then i'll stop i'll be
like
it's all good yeah it's so [ __ ] weird
if i see the hand like
sorry then i immediately defuse for sure
but the stakes are higher when you're
driving
like i'm not defending road rage because
it's definitely not okay and it should
you should not have it sounds like
you're defending it but i feel like if
you beat this [ __ ] out of somebody when
it's deserved it's totally fine i don't
know
that's what i thought road rage was it's
like when you're so [ __ ] aggressive
to the point where you're putting other
people in danger around you
like massively or like you're down to
park your car and [ __ ] confront the
person facebook i thought that was road
rage
i think that's like the the poster it's
depending on the person
it's so like everyone can get road rage
right so like but
the extent of yours might just be like
[ __ ] you
and then you're driving off but it's
just getting rage
yeah like feeling rage feeling that
anger because anything can happen right
cause you could you could not react in
the car and get super pissed off and
then be distracted by something else and
then get into an accident you know what
i
mean
oh my god those are like the instant
karma road rage videos those are great
those are great these are really fun i
like what they're all like
and then they go and then they crash
into like the center divider thing or
something
have you seen that truck where they like
cut them off and then they're pissed and
they're like swerving and then they
hit the center divider and like die and
they die yeah it's [ __ ] hilarious
that's what i always ask myself now
that's changed a lot for me it's like
if they piss me off right i'm like um
do i want to murder someone today oh
damn
nah that escalated quickly
and i said and if i say nah then i go
okay we'll just grip entirely his sword
you hear the steering but that's true
though
if you're gonna get out of the car in a
road rage incident
like you better be ready for some
[ __ ] action did you ever see the one
when it was two guys that
know mma that got out like four road
rage to like
i didn't see that and then they went off
and they actually started wrestling each
other and then they gave each other
props because they were like hey nice
that's nice hey that happens that
happens a lot at ufc
fights i've heard stories where people
started getting down and like they're
literally doing mma
and afterwards like all right you're
good and then sometimes you try to let
out your system
yeah and then you get it yeah that's a
guy in the middle in the middle of your
[ __ ] strangling each other you're
like
all right i think i'm i think i'm cool
now yeah yeah i gotta be cool all right
i'm cool
to a stranger if you understand like the
language but like in a street fight i'm
not gonna [ __ ] respect no tap out
that [ __ ] arm is getting broken
it depends it depends the situation
joe's gonna murder somebody you guys so
don't cut off joe
don't get joe [ __ ] with joe i'm not i
ask myself this question and i say
i don't want to
respect the tap respect
he's like i saw your jk news
[Laughter]
i'm subscribed
[Laughter]
i wouldn't know what to do man funny all
right anyway so on halloween night this
happened in florida keys
and man uh some road rage happened
top of the car no uh
that's usually what happens this is what
happened uh a guy named what was his
name
uh toby toby was driving toby he's in
the phobia
he's at a light all right red light and
uh a jeep pulls up right behind him all
right and the guys
y'all understand y'all know about the
whole uh confidence of overcompensating
when people drive lifted jeeps
yeah i think it's [ __ ] you think you
think you don't think it's true they
have huge wieners dude
huge wieners fart stick is huge oh okay
well then it's fact
yeah off-roading
that's usually the reality yeah true
yeah true what if what if it's like
always like
nice looking and like that like those
the room
this is clean you know what i mean all
the time giant and clean
is it still fun to like see those guys
in those trucks and be like
i got a little dick it's still kind of
funny it is funny it's funny yeah
whether you think it's true or not it's
still kind of but what about
the girls that drive those big trucks
are you like that is it she's probably
got big tits
big vagina tiny vagina it is
that's what people say about me when
they see me in my car like that guy has
a tiny vagina
[Laughter]
[Music]
turn the camera's off
[Laughter]
all right anyway so uh toby's driving
he's at a red light
uh jeep pulls up behind him his uh the
guy's name is dustin uh
tell me who the [ __ ] are these people
toby and uh
skyler came out of nowhere she's florida
keys yeah florida i don't know where the
little brother
where's florida keys i like that yeah at
the end of the
florida islands next to florida alicia
keys
okay now i know exactly where that's at
um pretty good i like it that was
fascinating
big fan of alicia keys here all right so
these guys are
all right so these guys are at a red
light they're right behind one right
behind the other
and the jeep starts revving up the
engine for no
no apparent reason of course because no
one respects a [ __ ] jeep writing
their engine
true nobody who cares whenever somebody
revs their engine no one's like oh dude
that guy's so [ __ ]
sick awesome it's the lamest [ __ ] ever
i've never heard a jeep
do you have do you yeah a rabbit in
there why it's a grand cherokee that's
like a mom jeep yeah it's not a wrangler
yeah but look all the trunk space you
have though that's pretty
it's good chunk space right being a jeep
is like revving a honda
what's wrong i got a honda i mean it's
like why are you [ __ ] on
[Laughter]
even the honda motorcycles i rolled one
this weekend it was like wait where's
the sound it
looks so cool but it just sounds like
that's because that's because people who
ride those have big
dicks yeah i don't want a big one
all right anyway so uh toby takes
offense to the revving
so when dustin's revving toby takes the
fence to it for
some reason so i i feel like in this
case uh toby might have instigated
whatever transpires next kobe sounds
insecure
[ __ ] yeah no dustin dustin right dustin
just had something in it
he just wants to try something you know
he doesn't know the context
mind you it's halloween night you know i
don't know what the [ __ ] they're doing
the halloween night in
florida you should have mentioned that
first kind of car does he drive they
don't say what toby's driving but
what toby does next is he gets out of
his car
and walks over homie he walks over to
the jeep he's like he's asking for why
are you revving your engine
bro and then this is what dustin says uh
does next did he bust to joe where you
open his door real quick
smack him in the face with a door no he
does not he does something much worse
so dustin in response to toby inquiring
why he's revving his engine
dustin whips out a gun and flashes it
and points it right at toby
toby flees calls the cops and gets
dustin arrested
now when the thing got dusty
a little [ __ ] ass dude it does toby
does sound
on the camera there it is
yeah all right so
now the interesting part now is when
dustin gets questioned by the cops
as to what transpired justin goes well
you know this guy he comes around the
car you know and he just
comes up to me and says you must have a
small dick
so i pulled out my gun out of self
protection
and that was the official statement from
dustin that's pretty tight dustin sounds
like a straight shooter
they both sound insecure as [ __ ] but
listen though at the same time if
somebody approaches your car
they get out of your car i would have my
gun too i feel like
because you don't know what they're
gonna do who gets out of their car no
for sure
to talk to you but the statement from
dustin is what makes me think he's also
highly insecure because then if it's
like really that's why you pulled out a
gun because he says
you have a small dick not because of the
fact that he approached you yeah but in
a road rage context if this dude comes
out of the car and he's approaching a
window and he probably did he probably
didn't say it nice
he probably wasn't like hey you have a
small dick yeah like hey is your dick
under two centimeters yeah yeah yeah he
came came out and
i really don't think it's because of the
statement yeah but it sounds like
i don't know what to expect from this
[ __ ] but who knows
maybe he never even said that maybe he
said why you're revving we don't know
because
the toby could be telling the truth
dustin who [ __ ] knows
true but the number one rule though if
you're in an altercation
on the street or something you don't get
out of your car you don't yeah if you
get out of your car that
[Laughter]
in my opinion though the person who got
out of the car is the aggressor
yeah if you step even though you didn't
make any aggressive like actions
or violent actions to me if you need to
get out of your car
to step out in the middle of traffic to
talk to somebody
yep and you're not asking for what if
he's hard at hearing
oh what's the point though so to me it's
like what's the point of confrontation
if you're not there to fight
facts what are you trying to do discuss
have a [ __ ] like
debate you're supposed to scare them and
make your ego feel better when you're
what are you saying
it's like i don't know if as soon as
someone is getting out of their car
if i'm armed i'm just having i'm not
gonna flash it but i'll have it in my
hand
because you don't know what the [ __ ]
they have because what if he has a gun
or what if he's pulling out a small dick
and he's showing
and he pees into your head here's a
picture of small dick dustin
and uh it looks like he has a huge dude
so young he looks like he's
yeah and he looks like he's scared yeah
he looks yeah this is a scared look in
his face that means
he looks like a chihuahua with luscious
hair they have a picture of toby
no questions does he look like he has a
small dick
no no it's usually the unsuspecting guys
that usually have the big
so you guys you girls you guys would
think this guy has a big deal i have no
clue no i have no
what's his shoe size he's like that's
the ultimate way to figure it out
how big are his hands yeah wait is that
even true no would it what if what if he
was like
officer some connection yeah what if he
was like officer as you're
[ __ ] flashing your hands why you have
big feet
hey look that guy right there that
matches
[Music]
[Music]
uh